foreign
y Is With Us in Kansas City hi Brittany
welcome to the Ramsey Show
how are you good how you doing
I'm good I'm I'm nervous to be here it's
okay how can we help
I had a quick question so I uh my
husband and I have had issues with
buying used cars we're not car people
and most recently we wanted a reliable
SUV and we had it for six months and the
engine locked up and we spent eight
thousand dollars on it and so we're
really looking for advice on
um what we should do next I it's it's
very tempting I feel like to buy a new
car and because we need something
reliable and we don't want to have to
um worry about uh buying a used car and
issues happening to it so I was
wondering your advice around that what
baby step are you on I'm just curious
um as I'm sorry
I'm new to like Dave Ramsey and
everything so can you explain that sure
I'd be happy to
um are you currently do you currently
have debt to pay off
so we have
50 000 in students Brittany I'm sorry
you cut out what'd you say
um I don't have any credit cards yet
good and we have 23 000
what's your household income
household income is 225. okay so you're
new to all things Ramsay and yet you
knew that we said don't buy a new car
brand new car unless unless you're a
millionaire
yes okay that's why I was nervous
but you're but that but okay so the
reason we don't want you to do that is
if you tie up uh tell me one more time
what your household income is
it's 2 25. okay all right
all right and and so what was the price
range of cars that you were driving that
were breaking
um eight thousand dollars eight thousand
dollars is what it costs all right
um now why why I'm making 225 000 a year
I mean given that you aren't doing
Ramsay stuff you just met us why were
you driving such cheap cars
well
um we had a so I have my car which is
already paid off it's a 2018 Malibu I
had already paid that off and then my
husband had a company car for the
longest time for like six years so he
was just driving his company car but how
long have you been making 225 000
um only for the last so three years ago
we were only making 160 then it jumped
to 225 and then where has all of your
money gone to
um
you make a lot of money have you been
paying down these student loans or
something like that or is it just
lifestyle
lifestyle I think and
um we did pay off
in the last six months we paid off all
of our credit cards
and we paid off
um well we paid for that used car but
here's the thing
here's the thing you got to sit down
tonight the two of you and go look we
got almost twenty thousand dollars a
month coming in
and we're and yet we're broke
so we need to determine what we're going
to do
with that income sit down look at what
your actual take-home pay is it's
probably more like
um your take-home pay is probably more
like 15.
okay yeah and so you're 15
000 a month you look you have a house
payment
we do have a house how much is your
house payment
my house payment is two thousand okay so
15 000 minus two thousand is thirteen
thousand and I want you to continue that
exercise
minus food minus lights and water
and um I think we're going to find a
disturbing amount of money
like ten thousand dollars a month
that is available to do things with and
that would tell me that you could save
up fairly quickly like before Christmas
and buy a 20 or 25 000 used car which is
an absolutely fabulous used car and she
could also get out of that student loan
debt and pay off the student loan debt
in the process yeah I mean you've got
but but what's happening is is that uh
you guys
let the scope creep happen to your
budget your lifestyle scope your life
the scope of your lifestyle creeped
crept up as you um without without
because you weren't paying attention and
that's not evil or bad or lazy even it's
normal but what's not normal is to pay
extreme amounts of attention to every
dollar the two of you together both
doing that and we lay out detailed goals
of exactly what we're going to do with
every free dollar we can squeeze out of
this budget uh and then what the next
thing is we're going to do with every
free dollar and so I hear two really
good big goals on this that I want to do
with the first forty thousand dollars or
fifty thousand dollars that I can get
out of your ten thousand dollar a month
disposable income so that's five months
and I and that's pay off the student
loan and buy a nice car
like that I like that plan a lot I mean
hey you see if you just lay down and go
and what that tells you then is we're
not going to go on vacation because we
want to do these other two things more
what that tells you is we're not going
to spend eight thousand dollars on
Christmas for God's sakes
right and what that tells us is is that
we're not gonna eat out every night for
300 bucks a night that's where it is
right there you know what this tells us
is is that uh we're not drinking any
more 500 bottles of wine which you
technically can afford but you really
can't because you are broke
yeah even though you have a fabulous
income and that's why you called us and
you're not a you're wonderful people and
you you're very smart people because
dumb people don't make two and a quarter
well if you do but not men
but but in that same breath uh you've
heard of those folks do live paycheck to
paycheck because of what you're talking
about right High income earning broke
people and if you look at yourself that
way then you'll go ah crap something's
got to change here I continue to do the
same thing over and over again expect a
different result that's the definition
of insanity I thought when we started
this conversation you were driving one
thousand dollar cars and spending two
thousand to keep them running and that
maybe you made forty or fifty thousand
dollars a year no she's in the Trap
because the the hard part with with your
situation is you make a good income and
it's so easy to lull yourself to sleep
and go oh we got money coming in we
don't have to look at it we don't have
to think about it we got good incomes
and then before you know it you're more
broke than the person making forty
thousand a year that just keeps eyes and
budgets on their money yeah
you and your husband sit down tonight
and say all right we're done
I'm done worried about a stupid broke
car in a house that makes 225 000. when
you say when you finally say I've had it
yeah that's the phrase that happens
right before you change your life
and just for anybody listening you can't
get a good eight thousand dollar car I
don't I want people to know you can you
can do it no but but yeah yeah
absolutely you can that's very possible
I mean she obviously got a bad one but
yeah uh but you know in your case the
cars are not the problem uh the old cars
are not the problem they're the symptom
of you being completely unintentional
and out of control with this fabulous
income that's right and that's not to
pick on you so I appreciate you calling
in here nervous and we're not throwing
you under the bus we've both done
exactly the same thing bad dumb stuff
with money too so we know it when we see
it I know what stupid looks like I used
to look at it in the mirror so uh you
know I'm not gonna not gonna ask you but
but here's the thing though I just want
to give you the power that comes to you
when you start telling every dollar what
to do and pointing every free dollar at
things that really matter more to you
than going out to eat this week
Now Dave what about that 500 bottle of
wine
if you make two and a quarter you can
drink a 500 bottle of wine if you're not
broke if you're not broke
guarantee you they have
I'll guarantee you should I need to make
some life lifestyle changes in here then
500 on a bottle of wine I didn't say you
had to
I said when you made a two and a quarter
it's an option if you're not broke
and so you know you got to get to where
you're not broke first so let's have you
know maybe we should base this on net
worth and not income okay
you don't want to be drinking your net
worth all right so let's just keep that
in mind that's right